[Music]
didn't affect how much [__] he gets
like he said he got more before he was
famous do you think that clout helped
you get [__] I definitely think it
helped but I was also getting a lot of
before so like my first week of school I
went to Florida Gulf Coast which was um
a public Florida University and I would
think I was with the new girl like
almost every single night there and
that's before I had any clout but now
it's different because you have a wider
variety of girls and girls now hit me up
which never used to happen someone call
College I still had to go up to them or
meet them in a dorm or some kind of [__]
like that and now they'll do like the
story likes they'll like a few posts
they'll follow you but have a cute
little profile picture so you just gotta
risk it and follow them and see if
they're hot or not I'd say like the
ability to talk to girls from different
places is a lot easier but if you have
the same game and everything I think
you'll you'll still do it right like we
said it's it's kind of like an amplifier
similar to money so if you can already
spit game to girls and now you have
clout it's just like a little extra XP I
think I get [__] but I think a little
Cloud would help it helps bro like I'm
not even alive right now they don't know
about the blue check marks that you can
buy them so when you bust that [__] out
at bars and stuff they're like oh my God
you're verified 50k bro I already tried
bro I I pay for a blue check mark it
said my ID wouldn't work and you only
get two attempts to submit your ID so it
still charged me and I didn't get the
blue check mark so
you got pranked so we're training with
um what's his face
I've got the nicest shoes on with dry
fit Nike socks like two thousand dollar
shoes dry fit Nike socks what socks
would you wear
it doesn't matter where I'm wearing bro
I ain't wearing that kind of drip or
this designer Tommy Hilfiger so he's gay
my mom buys my socks I don't even buy
these no you buy your own socks
only losers who don't have parents get
their socks buff for themselves you look
like you're about to move
Apartments
you look like you're gonna help someone
move right now
like you look like you're mid Health
like why is it you can see the [__]
shirt this isn't even my shirt is
Bronson shirt
no
I'm worried with sunny Fazio Sunny Fazio
got a wife yeah bro you gotta protect me
how do I get married I know it's coming
up to me in the streets man I'm super
famous
Sunday goes
today's mother
dude I'm the guy with the the mom I
don't usually just like get recognized
where people just come up to me like you
see snico and you're like oh [__] that's
Nico but I'll be talking to someone show
them what I do and they're like oh [__]
I've seen this before yeah with the mom
this is the guy with the mom have you
heard of the based mother it's always
really funny showing girls what you do
I'm like yeah I guess I do like YouTube
and stuff on the side and they look at
the channel and it's like oh like Mom
reacts to Andrew dates craziest takes
dude it's crazy getting having girls
reach out to you this [__] is new
so you take the beard and you say my
name is Teresa and this is my first beer
and you film this yourself drinking it
okay will you record me doing that one
of you yeah Teresa you doing wait do I
say this is my second shot yeah
only one shot of this [__] up is
[__] my name is Bronson Feller and
this is my second shot of vodka
everyone
[Applause]
I don't know what they're saying right
now I'm wearing my cardio Santos again I
gave the Rolex that Iman got to give it
to my dad I was gonna give him this and
he's like let me get the Rolex he said
that yeah
sure hey dad here's an expensive gift
hey at least you have a dad
this guy bro whoa what the film or
ruining them this guy needs therapy now
yo it's a Scion bro
what do you think about therapy okay 99
of the people that go to therapy in
America don't no 100 but like if I had
like family members that were
firefighters at 9 11 and they went and
that should help them I feel like that's
like a real [__] reason like you go
to war compared to like unpacking
childhood trauma because like it's just
stupid stuff you know my dad hit me one
time I mean he was 36.
okay it's also crazy seeing like the
people that become therapists you know
when you're young and you look at
teachers as like the truth the your word
is like gospel everything you say is
true and then you grow up and you see
the little house in high school and
they're like I'm gonna be a teacher
and those are the ones teaching the kids
remember I had that experience when I
was working at the restaurant and all my
old teachers came in and they were
talking about how they were like hoes in
college and put a blackout every night
and [__] I'm like you taught me bro
that's [__] what's up boys I hope
you're enjoying the Vlog real quick I
just wanted to give a shout out to
snico's creativity kit so I'm going to
be active income that's his money making
server I'm Gonna Leave the link at the
top of the description as well as my
online newsletter where I'm sending you
guys daily value emails on a lot of my
marketing tips how I got to 500 000 Subs
in a year I'm at around 2 billion views
across all my Brands right now so I know
this marketing stuff pretty well and I'm
just giving a bunch of free sauce to you
guys so check out those two links and
let's get back to the video there's a
lot of Italian people hey so so why
girls so I goes to the guy like hey man
Tony bring me to cannoli and then he
goes hey how's your mother your mother
and I go if you don't quit talking like
that about like a [__] break over
your head I said all right I'll tell you
something go [__] your mother
laughs
I don't expect this [__] mother I'm
gonna talk about my [__] mother in
front of me
[Applause]
beat you over the head with a loaf of
semolina dude I just met something fast
right now you want a picture yes
[Music]
you want to give an outro that was the
worst content I've ever seen that was
the worst all right let's go to my bed
[Music]
okay not two cameras in the same thing
is this show
you [__] stink hey me bro what do you
think it is chilly what the [__] are you
trying to say yo again you smell like
Curry man [__] you guys bro I showered
today bro you smell like adobo bro
that's a good smell yeah I don't think
so we got a playground right there I
forgot my cuties DVD at home so this is
gonna be great this is entertainment
what kind of vibe would you say this
place has if you look around at the
aesthetic I don't know if you have an
editor for this
who's going to my Vlog [__] your Vlog
this is kind of like an Epstein's Island
type of feel you know the white with the
little hints of blue you look around
like you look at the trees and
everything this is what it looked like
be peaceful there are a lot of little
kids you got to do what you want to do
no judgment no restrictions freedom
Freedom what do you have 400k or even
how to use a camera [__] useless all
of you it sounds you didn't have to go
through the trials and tribulations like
me with different tripods walking around
[__] sleepwalking and [__] you sound
like a geek
you can't use the camera look at you
holding this thing like why do why did
you bring the tripod why are you holding
it like that how else are you supposed
to hold this hold the camera oh you just
hold the camera I don't know why he
brought that little dorky little dildo
thing should look like animal beads I'm
here to learn from you guys you're the
professional vloggers where are the
chicas oh
that's your kind of secret right there
[Music]
yeah
it's a crazy shot I'm getting right now
goes missionary right now post for that
what's the plan for tomorrow how are you
gonna get them tomorrow more darts maybe
some booze yep no um I don't know last
time I thought what's Nico I was way
shittier I've gotten better I felt
really good the first round like I was
kind of keeping up with them and my
cardio just [__] [__] me [__] the bed
man more Ducks been drinking beers and
driven dogs in Europe can you try to get
back to it rip a [__] monk mode Let's
Get surgical punches to the face they
don't feel like anything like by the end
there I was getting whacked in the face
so much that's not what hurts he hit me
with like a medium shot to the kidney
and that hurt way more
shots didn't hurt head shots didn't hurt
you hit me in the body in the body then
you saw it because you were gas I'm like
this again I saw you going for the body
so I tried to get out
I don't know
oh who's gonna carry the boats
gonna go push
that's the easy 10 reps at least bro
come on come on
oh
[Music]
you have autistic schizo fingers that's
how autistically get your fingers
it's a weekend right now bro guys
schizophrenic it's the fortnite fingers
bro great building cranking too many 90s
be careful
it's not a Hellcat bro
he's gonna drive like a basketball
player for sure or taco American taco
just kidding I think the stir-fry
Americans Drive the worst
ride
on the Jurassic Park [__] I know that
was a weird comparison in comparison
throw a [__] banana
[Applause]
come on
the black one
[Applause]
oh
you look kind of drippy right now I just
dropped yeah we just dropped it just
landed bro where the [__] are we they're
about to pick us up we're gonna go
you're gonna pick us up and we're gonna
go head to the middle after this
[Music]
party
bro my how do you have the mask down the
whole time my mouth feels like it went
down on a grandma it doesn't hit the
second game
when he said it he said it like you said
hey it's like all right so I sense to
the guy so I goes he said before my
mouth feels like I went down on a
grandma like oh turn the camera and he
goes oh so my mouth is so dry it's like
I went down on a grandma like why are
you speaking like Seinfeld all right Bev
barely vlogged today
did a bunch of [__] work filming you
got a podcast what what's his name
Hassan absolute Banger make sure to
check that out yeah it was a good work
day got a lot of [__] done
content anything to say to the Vlog
is that the face you make when you when
you're watching cuties
sick of me
what the [__]
W racism good combos tonight got some
food with the boys about to get surgical
sneako said I can't get a girl tonight
but since he's Muslim now we can't make
a bet I think you got it man I just want
to let you know bro you don't need to go
use women for validation like it's okay
you know if they don't don't worry about
it man you just do you I mean it is
pride month I could always like I think
you should Express Yourself Sonny just
don't be afraid of judgment I know I
talk about like red pill stuff and
that you're going to hell but be you on
a serious note why do you think it's an
insult like the Liberals when they're
trying to insult you they always say
you're in the closet do you think it's
because they know that's secretly Haram
he's just he's farming me right now
I'm farming you you didn't Vlog all day
so he's just trying to milk all right
bro this guy's such a [__] [__]
[Music]